[Music]
dear Santa this is Kate Pierce I've been
really good this year I just say bad
words every now and then that's only
what my brother Teddy makes fun of me
and I lose my I made my tempered that
goes you're gonna break it who cares
it's cameras like 20 years old I have to
work it's Christmas Eve you're gonna
stay home with your sister we should
make a video maybe we should get a shot
of Santa Claus you really have no clue
do you
nobody's ever
sir cause tell me you're getting this do
you realize how big of a deal with it we
need to get a closer look crazy
[Music]
easiest position hold on to something
live and in person one night only can
you go I don't go ho ho ho that's a myth
Christmas spirits down 35% half the
planets not gonna get toys so a few
brats don't get presents that's not the
end of the world people need Christmas
to remind themselves of how good they
can be Wendy you've got so big excuse me
you know what I mean grown up big now
Wendy we need a ride can you call an
uber you think I can pay the driver with
these imagine if we all work together
this just might work you need to rally
the reindeer calm it and bind the elves
please bless it
can you guys succeed maybe we can still
save Christmas
so
less than an hour before the Sun rises
whoa let's get this party started
[Applause]
[Music]
just like wait for Hanna and Jedi
mind-trick the cop I'm Santa Claus Teddy
not Yoda okay that's enough fun for one
night
why must they keep drawing me like that
does my butt really look that thank you
[Music]